I'm back he says well look who's coming
in no cuz I waved at him it just sat
down hi IRA Holmes technology expert IRA
the weather man I were welcome to Jim
Norton and Sandra thank you very very
much yeah thank you
there's it to be back on Sirius radio
with Sam Roberts and Jim Norton ah
that's very nice and we're very very
happy to have you back you very much so
first time doing this show yes yes yes
you must be excited I am excited
so you're I you must be very sad that
Jay passed away yes but life has to go
on
alright no need to grieve on the air
Jesus yeah I noticed that the very quick
reading period the voicemail to pop back
on the air came very very quickly after
the passing of Jay you were ready to
crack those mic yes he called from the
lake I called up every day practically I
did I do apologize I noticed that
because I don't check my voicemail all
the time which you obviously found out
because I had many voice mails from iris
saying Sam when you're gonna get the
weather driving back on the show I mean
Here I am that's right what have you
been doing with your life man it's been
a long time since we spoke to you well
yeah you know where i go to i go to
Yonkers racetrack it's in that's
actually in Westchester also known as
the best yesterday
are you big on you big a horsing race
guy no I don't play the horses
I played the machines he plays the [ __ ]
Jim how do you do I do move pretty good
there I break out even funny that's I
couldn't so what's the most you've lost
I lost given that so much but I gave up
in Atlanta City but no he lost more than
a thousand bucks in a day no oh I don't
lose a thousand bucks who's got that
kind of cash right I don't bring your
thousand bucks with me period what do
you bring when you go it's just like
what will you bring for a day two to
twenty five to forty okay okay not bad
and if I lose that I lose that but
sometimes I gain up
yeah never 250 though no no that's a
little much
that's a little much Atlantic City I
bring a little bit more money why is
that because I go far away to Atlantic
City I get it it's like a vacation
almost that's right I see where you stay
I go to three casinos uh-huh
I go to Bally's I go to Tropicana and I
go to Resorts I do very very good who do
you go with I go with the bus oh just
like a bus great how important I see I
see you never bring a lady up there with
you no are you seeing anybody right now
nobody really nice because I remember
wait didn't you you brought in a lady oh
yes I brought this lady
Laverne writes right we're having to
hurt she's still around hey he's still
headed I don't see that so much why not
you got sick of it I change she has a
tape machine on she records you know a
tape machines I can't because she babies
with a machine is on Oh answering
machine actually I see well you got you
got other I better find pieces right I
got other people that's right right
that's good see though there are there
are other ladies you're seeing that's
right any uh keep on with same one all
the time
no no you got a relationship guy that's
right no you kind of play the field a
little bit's right for you man you have
a different young lady that you're
engaged with yes right um do you have
sex on the first date or do you prefer
to wait I preferred to wait what a
gentleman how long how long yeah made a
few months months that your choice maybe
two months why two months of cause you
have to get to know the person before
sex yeah do you agree with that Jim no I
don't would you ever have sex on the
first date I mean know the gender half
the time IRA watch this guy huh
yeah so when was the last time you went
on a date yeah I have a lady friend in
the house you do
you live with lady wall bothers you and
normally live together Laverne and Norma
who nice not too bad how long you been
living with Norma
long time how long since I met over in
Rosalind years ago oh she's been there
for a long time long time so did you uh
yeah okay how old is Norma she
appropriate age around 5500 Kyra not bad
no that's a little younger huh yeah
that's not bad
you like him a little younger oh I love
them younger what's a good age for you
do you think ah roughly 40 forties okay
well how old are you 73 years old my
million I am a veteran I think you were
yeah why I thought you a much younger
guy than that you look great 73 is what
were you Vietnam that no no veteran of
what at the Korean love from a hospital
I you so be employee of a hospital wait
as being a veteran no you know what you
ever in a war never okay so what do you
have veteran of this is a case of stolen
valor I think yeah I think so too
we got a little bit of Stafford man
sergeant in the chip army a little
stolen valor there well yeah what are
you a veteran of you never fought a war
well I'm an employee I used to work in a
health and hospital corporation from
1968 to 2002 did you work on sick
animals no I delivered the mail Dino
mail you got a PhD in mail yeah that's
crazy you're a male veteran Mel deliver
the mailbox mail delivered mail oh okay
so that's so it is technically a veteran
show yeah when they say honor our vets
they mean people who have delivered the
mail as well not just you've gotten
their legs shut off okay so you must
learn so Veterans Day is a big day for
you
oh yes Fred waiting to say is a big day
for me cuz that's your dailies that's
right talking to the mic that's right so
uh so what do you do what do you do with
your time so you did you retire
in 2002 yeah besides doctors I retired
2002 and Bloomberg and Pataki gave the
early outs a check right that's right
what do you do to pass the time besides
I wore stories with other mail carriers
I don't want to say this on the air but
I have to warm up different you see I
got an iPod at home like baby oh yeah
exactly
yes I call up them from places I call
them Connecticut on your icons right oh
that's incredible how do you call things
on your iPod Wow do you notice that
everyone who answers is singing a song
[Laughter]
right yeah so what do you who do you who
do you call just random people different
station a radio station radio station oh
I see funk Connecticut to Jersey can you
listen to them all of you sometimes yeah
you do how's your health you look at the
thinner glass - okay feel great how much
weight I used to wait - 17 i rave 187
that's great right you look great that's
right
I do Zumba what does that look like very
very nice yeah where do you go for that
where do you go for that
oh I go on downtown on 12 Street in
Manhattan
this is Zumba class yes isn't that like
dancing ethnic dancing yeah
how often do you go every every
Wednesday so once a week you do Zumba
twice a week I did let's do the zoom
bomb Mondays at you Kobe oh and
Wednesday and it's a one hour class one
hour class and you will do and you will
dance for an hour yes
what do you wear when you work out same
that's probably about right you are a
collared shirt my shirt
oh I follow you words the t-shirt okay
what kind of music do they play in Zumba
class different music music I can use it
I would love to see some yeah can you
show us a move that you learned in Zumba
class oh yeah I'd love to see if you can
stand up for a second just show us yeah
hold on let's get some music to do any
music yes we have some Zumba music like
oh no no not yet I we gotta get a camera
something with a steel drummer not yet
right a lot of steel drum and Zumba I
think so right yeah sure yeah here let's
let's just get you some users headphones
on so you'll be able to hear the Zumba
music that we have play mega tone Travis
is gonna get put on some sharper have
some duty rock yeah play on and I get
busy yeah that's that seems like Zumba
music of course it does okay gonna be
great
let's see cuz I want to see if it's if
it's a good workout method because I'm
actually looking to get a little more
fit myself wow you're really moving yeah
it's great
that's your smile is contagious I wrote
yeah he dances like the veteran and One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest and spinning
around [ __ ] day room yes
it's very good the mobility out I no
wonder you're wasting away with moves
like that yeah are you buddy this is
good stop yeah that was exactly like the
day room dance that guy did it really
was yeah Helen you've been zooming a
long time okay so that's years of work
years of work that you'd run into that
that's okay so that's why it looks so
advanced from 93rd Street to 74th Street
why it's a nineteen block hike why do
you why that why those specific roads I
like to walk
but why those specific 71 ounces 20
blocks well that's 75 20 March I like
warm 19 yes I lose weight in every way
you but you went from 94th to 73rd or
the 93rd 33rd to 74 that's 19 blocks why
did you start at 93rd well that's where
my cynic
oh I see so you go to the synagogue yes
and then you walk to Zumba class no then
I walk down to 74th Street on Saturday
afternoon well what's on 74th Street
just walk around sit in the park over
there boy so why do you stop at 74th
Street then I guess is the question yeah
like why not just 20 blocks why not go
to 73rd Street then you've got an even
20 no maniac guy right well he's a weird
with numbers because they pull the mic
towards you I can't stacking up my
buddies trying to go towards him yeah I
know you're weird with numbers that's
like he'll bring the money he brings the
money he brings his 225 or 240 he brings
he says strange numbers it's specific
yep there's a specific meaning to these
numbers
who is the delightful lady you have with
you you know Christina oh I did not
recognize your mind it's good to see you
I thought you were related to Ira no
we're taking all the Jay Thomas people
okay go hey Christine acquiesce I want
to speak to you for a second - I didn't
know it was you I'm sorry sir do you
mind if we speak to Christina no you're
a big Christina guy right big fan of
Christina I love her she's sweet hey
Tina yeah how long have you been away
from serious
well no I'm last show was August 7th so
that's the last time that we were on the
air with Jay okay oh so you are doing it
right up until the end hey we're having
Kevin meanie friends at the end they had
a little bit of a falling out was it
always over him with the gay stuff right
did they ever make up for that yeah no
they never got a chance to because Kevin
died right wow that's like yeah bummer
Kevin and Jay both passed away man it's
like it's Turbots awful yeah I feel like
I'm the curse or something I don't you
how do you think I feel oppa Anthony oh
uh Wow Jade I I know it was all very
sudden so what are you doing now uh well
I'm here with IRA right now I'm sure
there's some things that I guess are
supposed to be you know coming up and
it's like the Mafia you know there's a
lot of secrets I don't know yet what's
happening he's still working here though
yes oh you are okay good do people
around here know that Jay was sick
because like I was I didn't know for
like I had no clue Jay didn't want
anybody to know
that he was sick so there was just a
handful of people that knew was it
cancer or heart it was cancer oh my god
what cancer is it lung cancer well he
you know five years ago he had some
issues in his throat and then when it
about five years later it came back at
metastasized you know was he a smoker no
no but you know what he was it was
yesterday DJ you know for years I mean
you know eating all kinds of [ __ ] and
drinking all kinds of things and smoking
all kinds of cigarettes and so he did
smoke cigarettes well not he never
smoked cigarettes but you know as a DJ
back in the day when you were doing all
kinds of nutty stuff and you know so I'm
sure like his body had taken a toll but
it wasn't anything specific that
pussy-eating scares me you think you got
it for me of course no but I just think
everybody's gonna die from eating [ __ ]
yeah one of my you know that's it I know
for a fact I'm probably gonna go from
ovarian cancer and you guys are all
gonna die yeah Wow so these women are
gonna kill everybody yeah feel like
we're our own enemies yes well it is
kind of scary I've gotten checked for
throat cancer a whole bunch of times
they need so much [ __ ] deceased
I mean I think in the box so much no but
sometimes I'll kiss the woman down to
the thighs not just go like what were
you do what we do this tastes like it
doesn't matter what do you do but unless
fingers know wasn't my thing right what
I do light touch doesn't work but in the
moments passed
it sure has but I hit it twice and it
just stiffened up on me yeah wow that's
uh something that your penis doesn't do
for you oh it does
oh it does thanks to your talented lips
[Laughter]
yeah you have figured out a way to avoid
getting cancer from eating [ __ ]
recently though you bet I have so uh
it's gonna be a rectal so now Michael
Douglas it's so funny he's the face of
HPV cancer how embarrassing my own
personal weird yeah but you gotta be I
do get I have my nose check recently
like hey look at the throat make sure
everything is good and they check you
should
check that IRA oh yes how often you go
doctor what see I go to my GI doctor
every three months is very good GI
doctor what is this hold on what is it
with you and stolen valor
yeah but you said GI doctor like it's a
doctor that sees GI so people who fought
in a war or dealers avail yes is I write
when I wrote on J Thomas's show did he
was he a guy who was into stolen valor
because he's making a lot of claims
about being a member of the military yes
I don't think he ever was where do I
mean IRA was a respected you know
mailman at Jacobi Medical Center and IRA
does a lot for the vets he does a lot
for the Democratic Party doesn't make
involved it doesn't make him a veteran
and so not a veteran but he is so it's
with veterans so where'd you get your
radio chops with Adrian Cronauer in
Vietnam so what do you do for the devil
could you only big Democrats somebody's
headquarters here the day
don't be so specific Joan I mark Jonah
it was running for City Council and he
won so you're a big Trump guy then oh I
don't I hate what you do
yeah I'm white what's turned you off my
plane LGBT Hillary make it well what
what do you not like about Trump
why'd you vote for Trump I didn't vote
for Trump oh what made you what is it
what turned you off about Donald Trump
as a candidate for president because we
did a lot of things wrong in Atlantic
City he closed up two casino it all
comes back to the casino wait wait so
when you say you bring to 25 or to 40 do
you mean $225 or do you mean okay yes
not $2 I'm 44 get it
or 40 cents at the penny slot so he'd
give you a good time I was a fascinating
guy to watch him gamble is like nothing
you've ever seen before he has a whole
system he's got some money so he takes
it very seriously
does he like to be left alone no he's a
social guy okay
social guy but he doesn't you know he
pays attention he has two specific
machines and you know if there's
something that he wants to go for he'll
go for it
a lot of people love IRA you know a lot
of ladies love IRA yeah I could see not
bad sometimes they approach him if
they're too old he's not really
interested I like that about him he was
telling us he likes a much much young
well you guys were talking about Zumba
before I actually accompanied IRA to is
dry yes I did at the senior center the
Jewish Senior Center he wore khaki pants
t-shirt and a sweater vest it was the
most amazing thing I've ever seen in my
life when he walks in IRA everybody's so
happy to see they all love him all the
women move and get to him with their
Zumba moves and then I said to him I
wrote some good-looking till here why
don't you see if any of these ladies
want they aren't too old do you got his
Hannah yes I saw the the the women in
this Zumba class they're a little too
old for you
yes that's what you sold till I read
doesn't want to [ __ ] any woman that's
ever owned a record player yeah yeah I
mean you got a you got a why not it
looked like there are some women in
there they're probably in like their
forties and fifties they're on so why
wouldn't you see if they want to you
know see me as you don't like that would
you have sex with a thirty year old no
no gotta be in the too young too young
too young
okay it's it's very specific yeah white
why not that too young thirty year old
too young so it's gotta be in their 40s
40s that's a disease that's the sweet
spot is that right that is right that's
right that's right well you know it's
smart because you don't want some broad
that wants to have kids and all this
stuff no way
once you're like mid-40s into your 50s
that's out of your system then you're
ready for IRA is that right that's right
that's right yeah you want a nice
[ __ ] boarded up home I understand
that
right he doesn't want anybody coming for
the inheritance I understand yeah it
makes sense
IRA wants to [ __ ] a someone you don't
like pulling out I bet no you're a dump
it inside guy yeah so happy today
Tommy maybe the grand reunion on Sirius
radio with Sam and Jim naught that's
right and your Cena too right okay yeah
no of course not
so uh should we get a I guess a weather
chance is gonna be 80 degrees today
partly cloudy and tomorrow around 80
degrees beautiful skies and over the
weekend chance of a little bit showers
but that's gonna be it why don't you
give the west coast to be fair West
Coast California around 65 degrees
sometimes just guesstimate with the LA
he does
no no no he's accurate who doesn't use a
Doppler he is accurate there's two
things that I or the weatherman knows
very much about that's penny slots and
the weather don't dump it inside he
showed al roker up one day so I mean I
heard on the radio that it was gonna
rain today but you tell me I heard I'm
going to light rain today
two o'clock it's not gonna rain at all
Oh to a human
put them to the test you'll see that's
great news that's great what good thing
I didn't bring an umbrella then yeah
must been very valuable field cuz you're
gonna bring an umbrella that's what you
can do when you were when you were
serving the military would you ever in
the military Oh with us before didn't he
say before the a veteran yeah yeah I was
gonna ask like when you were away at war
did you ever have to forecast the
weather like for the troops never okay
alright did you tell these fine
gentlemen that you were a veteran yeah
he did he did i veteran employee o of
Jacobi Medical Corps she said he was a
veteran then he said he was a veteran
Naomi
right a hospital yeah yeah he cleared
that up a little a little bit after a
little bit yeah he did a mystery oh yeah
nothing I I did mention but you were a
veteran that's pretty amazing yeah and
he goes on no no I thought this maybe in
Korea or Vietnam but he cleared that up
immediately
so what do you think so what's tickling
your fancy on the radio these days I
returned array do like what's uh what's
really crushing it right now
what's crushing it right now yeah what
about you in Connecticut you can talk
about it oh okay it's a new London
that's right that's the big stage the
Roxy radio station now they call it
cahit's
and that's the big event it's in Norwich
Connecticut okay yes I am the weatherman
on Friday mornings coincidence I call up
Gibbs in the London weather forecast
that's great
I don't know why you don't have a
regular gig on TV like he's an
entertainer and I'm maybe you could do
something for me Jim maybe something for
me first I can't get me onto you start
like a YouTube thing oh when you start
doing weather reports on YouTube like
that dumb kids daily weather app oh
maybe I you know my god IRA's weather
but where do you do it for you do just
put it on YouTube no no what I mean is
like you know that'd be a daily apathy
great it's got do it every day though
but where do you read the weather for
Chicago just rattle off the major cities
I mean let's be honest IRA is human it's
it's he's charisma in human form like
people aren't really gonna download this
app for theirs well you're right you're
gonna download this app for the IRA
that's true true you know and I think
you know IRA gives the weather then
maybe he gives his take on a couple
things going on or whatever it gives a
little opinion yes some radio fax yeah
yeah a little Zumba lesson how often do
you go to a temple once a week Oh
once week last week oh you would do that
you say once then you go twice twice so
you said that was tomba 2 how often once
a week really yes nice a week so
actually so uh now how
you know Friday night to services begins
at seven o'clock finishes around 10 a.m.
to rate the quarter after wait ok little
over an hour that we haven't dinner
we're in this synagogue you were gearing
up for morning just stop and then just
stop okay
so what do you have for dinner chicken
do you like you filled the fish
oh yeah it's terrible gefilte fish is
number one no it's number two shitty
Oh terrible another thing that IRAs
really good at is finding all the free
meals that are to offer in New York City
right you've got it down pat where do
you find free meals at ira free meals
downtown twelve Street in Manhattan
that's a good Street for you yes three
meals Zumba that's great well they have
to buy a beach every Wednesday and I
have to go there sure you do what kind
of where do you get free meals from a
downtown 12 Street said to random
centers that he belongs to
isn't that for like people can't afford
to eat like no it's just just for people
would like a meal apparently yeah yeah
cuz you get the Bloomberg checks you
said that's right so then can you just
can you just buy lunch
you buy lunch if you want to spend money
for lunch but that's my lunch but you
don't want to spend money for lunch now
that they have is very very good
yesterday they had salmon yeah very very
delicious are you going down there today
no no that's it I'm going to a different
center to me Oh what are you do it a
different center for free lunch yes okay
so he does have no over there they
charge 225 whoa now that actually is to
know they they have fish you don't mind
the fish though oh no I love fish right
I do to knock a filter no it's not
salmon salmon a filter this is cold
right go further finishes cold
let's get that [ __ ] gooey like gel
around us all right what do you use on
a horseradish right I like horseradish
but gefilte fish is abominable your
filter fish is delicious
hey do you think do you think do you
think Donald Trump is anti-semitic you
know that's accusation that's been
hurled his way doesn't like anybody know
so it's not see the thing is choosing
black strength I do you think it's just
in general the worse worse
well you you're you you supported them
and this is why I did not support him I
think for Hillary oh now I do you
believe in climate change your weather
guy oh no you know climate change that's
ridiculous
global warming no no that's a clear say
that right we got warming trend right
right now there's no global warming not
within how come there's been such bad
hurricanes like these the worst
hurricane oh this is worse hurricane
season that bad habit but it's not
because of global you have Harvey right
we had a rumor that we have all say that
we have but it didn't come up the coast
but this isn't because of global warming
now so why is it happening it's
happening I see okay that makes of years
you get hurricanes show me is you don't
get hurricane right